[संगीत]
सो हेलो गैस मैं ए गया हूं फिर से एक
क्वेश्चन लेकर अपना एसक्यूएल का
थोड़ा छोटा हो सकता है
वह मतलब अगर मैंने उसके बताया तो शायद वो
आप कॉन्सेप्ट भूल जो इसलिए छोटा है लेकिन
थोड़ा समझना अपने को जरूरी है उसको
क्योंकि वह आपके बहुत जगह पर कम ए सकता है
क्योंकि आइसक्रीम जंक्शन में मिली वो कम
आता ही है देखा जाए तो इसके लिए आज की
क्लास छोटी हो शक्ति है लेकिन इंपॉर्टेंट
है
क्लासेस अपना जरूरी नहीं की 1 घंटे का ही
हो बट फिर भी
शायद मैं कल कुछ कमांड्स बताना भूल गया था
अपना इसका
[संगीत]
तो आज वह कमेंट्स कर करेंगे
ठीक है तो सेट ऑपरेटर क्या करते हैं सेट
ऑपरेटर क्या करते हैं ना वो दो या दो से
अधिक
अलग-अलग टेबल से हो शक्ति है उनको कंबाइन
करके एक सिंगल रिजल्ट ला के देते हैं
बेसिकली दो अलग-अलग टेबल्स की क्वेरीज
होती हैं
ठीक है तो एक सिंगल रिजल्ट में लाकर देती
है ठीक है इसे क्या कहते है ना मां लो
आपको है ना अपना वेबसाइट वगैरा के अंदर एक
ही कमांड पे आप इंजेक्शन कर पाते हो मतलब
एक ही जगह पे इंजेक्शन कर पाते हो लेकिन
आपको इंजेक्शन पे ऐसे कमांड देखनी पड़ती
है जिसकी वजह से आप अपनी टेबल के साथ-साथ
बाकी टेबल्स को भी इफेक्ट कर सको ताकि
आपको सबका डाटा एंट्री होता रहे ठीक है तो
वो चीज अपन को करना वो जरूरी से हो जाता
है इस चक्कर में अपन सेट और थोड़ा सा
अच्छी तरीके से देखने वाले हैं
अपने पास कर टाइप्स के ऑपरेटर रहते हैं
ठीक है
तो कर में से अपना सबसे पहले आता है
यूनियन ऑपरेटर ठीक है ना यूनिनॉर ऑपरेटर
क्या करता है ना की मां लो अपने पास दो
टेबल्स हैं तो दोनों टेबल्स में से
डुप्लीकेट रिकॉर्ड्स को छोड़ के बाकी सारे
रिकॉर्ड जैसे अगर दोनों टेबल के रिकॉर्ड
दिखाएगा बस डुप्लीकेट रिकॉर्ड्स को सिर्फ
एक बार ये दिखाएगा ठीक है उनको रिपीट नहीं
करेगा
यूनियन जो ऑपरेटर क्या करता है ना की दो
अपन फिलहाल 2 टेबल बताएंगे दो से अधिक भी
आप लगा सकते हो ठीक है ना दो से अधिक करके
आप लोग दिखाना आप लोग अरा है तो मुझे
बताना मैं जरूर उसका सॉल्यूशन कर दूंगा
अपने टेलीग्राम चैनल के अंदर और टेक्निकल
चैनल वगैरा जॉइन कर सकते हो हमारे आ
डिस्क्रिप्शन से
ठीक है तो यूनियन जो जो करता है वो सारे
रिकॉर्ड्स प्रिंट करेगा चाहे डुप्लीकेट हो
चाहे नहीं हो उसको फर्क नहीं पड़ता है
तो दोनों टेबल से रिकॉर्ड शो करेगा
ना की अपना फर्स्ट टेबल के रिकॉर्ड तो
दिखाएगा और साथ में अगर फर्स्ट लेवल के
अंदर कोई सेकंड टेबल वो हटा के ओनली
फर्स्ट फर्स्ट लेवल के जो रिकॉर्ड ओनली
फर्स्ट लेवल से बिलॉन्गिंग सिर्फ वही
दिखाएगा ठीक है ना और जो इंटरसेक्ट ऑपरेटर
है वो अपन को सिर्फ आम रिकॉर्ड दिखाएं
इनके अभी अपन सामने प्रैक्टिकल
रिप्रेजेंटेशन भी करेंगे ठीक है टेबल से
अपन आपके इस भी बनाएंगे अब इसमें डाटा वन
सेट करेंगे तो उसका ज्यादा टेंशन मत करना
इस्तेमाल
यूनियन ऑपरेटर उससे पहले अपन एक अलग से
टेबल सेट कर लेते हैं ताकि अपन सिचुएशन
बना सकते हैं जैसे सिचुएशन के अंदर अपन
अपने मतलब
शो कर सुकून तो उसे सिचुएशन क्रिएट करने
के लिए सबसे पहले तो मैं एक कम करता हूं
कनेक्ट कर लिया
[संगीत]
ठीक है यह टेबल क्रिकेटर
मैंने यहां पर वैल्यू
पट करना है तो प्लीज जो लोग लास्ट स्टेशंस
नहीं देखें हैं वह लोग सेशंस देख लेना था
की उन लोगों को यह चीज समझ में ए जाएगी
सब ठीक है तो मैं वापस
इंसर्ट हो गई है
और कुछ नहीं है यहां पर कंट्रोल
सी दबाओगे तो ये बैंड हो जाएगा
भूल मत कर देना
दिखे जाएगा
ठीक है
उसको
यहां पर परसों तू दाल देता हूं
एक दो तीन कर पांच पांच डाटा उसने भी
डालूंगा
ताकि मैं आपको अच्छे से इमोशन दे पाऊं की
क्या होते हैं जो मैंने आपको चार्ट बताया
वो क्या-क्या कर रहे हैं उसके अंदर
तीन थोड़ा यहां से ले लेट हूं
[संगीत]
बड़ा मां जाएगी
की हमको हिंदी में वीडियो सीखना चाहिए
वीडियो
फेसबुक
के अंदर वीडियो
देखना है मेरे को कमांड लिख कर दो परसों
वन टेबल से मुझे सर का सर डाटा देखने
का क्या डाटा है तो प्लीज मुझे कमांड
लिखकर दो ताकि मैं यहां पर लिख सुकून
कमांड
टेबल से
एसडी
बताओ
मैंने यह दिया था विकास के अंदर
बताओ यार
सिलेक्ट
स्टार फ्रॉम
[संगीत]
यहां पर टेबल फर्स्ट टेबल
आज क्या हो रहा है मेरे को पता नहीं
परसों वन
परसों तू ठीक है
ना
सबसे पहले
तो सबसे पहले इसमें यह दिखाए
लॉटरी
दिया है मतलब जैसे अपन ऑर्डर बाय अपन ने
कमांड के इस्तेमाल किया था तो इसमें खुद
से अपन को ऑर्डरिंग करके दिए ठीक है ना तो
ये मत समझना की ये कैसा आउटपुट ए रहे हो
ऊपर नीचे है जाएगा सर
तो देखो
यहां पर थे ठीक है
तो इस चक्कर के अंदर जो रिपीटेड था उसने
एक बड़ी दिखाए
करता है
तो यूनियन के बाद अपना नेक्स्ट आता है
अपना यूनियन और यह सारे रिकॉर्ड दिखाएगा
कोर्स जैसा नाम वैसा कम
ठीक है तो अब मैं अगर यहां पर यूनियन और
लिखना हूं तो
दिखा रहा था
रिपीट डाटा
ठीक है ना यह कम कॉलम्स पर ही मेली कम
करेंगे
तो यार देखो की ना एक कंपनी की एम्पलाई की
टेबल बंटी है ठीक है ना और एक कंपनी का
मैनेजर की टेबल बंटी है अब जब देखा जाए तो
मैनेजर एक एम्पलाई है तो एम्पलाई टेबल के
अंदर भी आएगा ठीक है
तो वो मैनेजर की भी टेबल में आएगा वो
दोनों टेबल्स में रिकॉर्ड रहेंगे बट अपुन
को कुछ ऐसे रिकॉर्ड देखने हो की यार की
कौन से बंदे हो कुछ साइन नहीं हुआ है ठीक
है ना तो उसे कैसे के अंदर अपन यूनियन का
इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं या दोनों टेबल्स में
से मां को देखना है सब कुछ तो यूनियन जो
के इस्तेमाल कर सकते हैं
की मैं चाट नहीं देखा हूं तो भाई मैं चाट
पूरे देखा हूं ठीक है
यहां तक आपको तक आते थे वो चीज सिर्फ डिले
हो जाति है ठीक है ना तो इतनी मत समझना
मेरे को दिखने में ए जाता है ऐसा नहीं है
मैं यहां पर डिलीवरी कर चुका हूं तो आपको
सेकेंड्स के बाद में आपको दिखता है तो ठीक
है ना
तो सब कुछ देखने के लिए
और रिपीट
तो देखो कुछ नहीं जैसा
होगा उसको सिर्फ सिंगल टाइम दिखाएगा ठीक
है
यह रिकॉर्ड है यह दोनों टेबल्स यह टेबल वन
यह टेबल तू
ठीक है ना यह रिपीटेड रिकॉर्ड्स अपन को
नहीं दिखाएगा रिपोर्ट
डाटा एक बार ही दिखाएगा है और अपना दो
डाटा रिपीट हो रहा था
दो फर्स्ट टेबल में से और दो सेकंड टेबल
में से ये हमारा था ये चेक करने का उसने
बस एक बार इसको दिखाए
यूनियन के बड़े में यूनियन जो सब कुछ
दिखाएगा यूनियन बस रिप्रेस्टेड डाटा नहीं
दिखता है
एक बार ही दिखाएगा ठीक है
ना
समझना चाहिए
आप मेरे खाने पर
मैं दोनों टेबल फिर से खोल देता हूं
सिलेक्ट स्टार
परसों वन
माइंस
ठीक है
दूसरी वाली टेबल है रिपीट हो रहा था तो
माइंस ऑपरेटर क्या कर रहा है ना ये पहले
वाला टेबल का तो पूरा दिखा रहा है लेकिन
पहले वाले टेबल में से वो ही डाटा दिखा
रहा है जो लेटेस्ट सिर्फ पहले वाले टेबल
के अंदर है दूसरे वाले टेबल के अंदर जो है
डाटा जो रिपीट हुआ है फर्स्ट वाली टेबल से
ही वो डाटा यहां पर नहीं दिखा रहा है मेरे
को फिर से रिपीट करता हूं की माइंस और बटन
क्या कर रहा है वो अपन को फर्स्ट लेवल में
से रिकॉर्ड दिखा रहा है बट सेकंड टेबल के
रिकॉर्ड जो है जो फर्स्ट लेवल के अंदर भी
रिपीट हो रहे हैं उनको हटा के दिखा रहा है
मतलब ओनली वही यूनिक यूनिक ही अपन को
सामने दिखाएगा
मैंने सफेद समझना है की नहीं
फर्स्ट सेमेस्टर
अब अपने एक और बच्चा इंटरसेक्ट
अपना जो
ऑपरेटर है वह सिर्फ अपन को दोनों टेबल्स
में से जो आम है सिर्फ वही दिखा रहा है
आपको ओन्ली आम रिकॉर्ड्स एक बार दिखाई हैं
बाकी दोनों टेबल्स में से रिकॉर्ड दिखता
है ठीक है
जो डाटा रिपीट हो रहा है उसको सिर्फ एक
बार ही दिखाएगा यूनियन जो ऑपरेटर सब कुछ
दिखाएगा रिपीट हो रहा नहीं हो रहा है इसको
बिल्कुल फर्क नहीं पड़ता है ठीक है
फर्स्ट लेवल में से रिकॉर्ड दिखाएगा लेकिन
जो रिकॉर्ड अपना सेकंड टेबल के अंदर भी है
वो रिकॉर्ड को हटा देगा ओनली वही रिकॉर्ड
डिगा जो बिलॉन्ग करता है अपने फर्स्ट टेबल
से ठीक है
इंटरसेक्ट ऑपरेटर क्या करेगा
समझ में आएगा
ओके
किसी को क्वेश्चन इन चारों ऑपरेटर
चलो कोई नहीं
तो अगर आज तक अभी अपने पास बहुत टाइम ले
गया
बस इंतजार
ठीक है
ठीक है तो देखो ना यहां पर एक डाटा नल में
अगर मेरे को ऐसा अगर मुझे ऐसा कोई चाहिए
की यार जिसके अंदर फोन नंबर खाली है मुझे
उनके रेट ला दो ताकि मैं अगर उसको रियल
लाइफ एग्जांपल देखते तो अपन जब किसी को
रिक्वेस्ट करते क्या है आपने ये डाटा
खेलने की केवाईसी कंप्लीट नहीं हो राखी है
या फिर आपने आप अगर लेटर पद आ बेस्ड हो
किसी को की आपका ये नहीं हो रखा है वो
नहीं हो रखा आप एड्रेस डालो ये डालो
पेमेंट की डीटेल्स डालो तो उसके निशान में
अपन ने ना अपनी टेबल्स में से चेक करते
हैं की बंदे ने क्या फूल नहीं कर रहा था
क्या उसने कोई नल छोड़ रखा है क्या तो वो
वो देखने के लिए अपन क्या करते है ना अपन
एक छोटी सी कमल लखनी होती है यहां पर
जो मुझे कलम को देखना है
तो देखो यहां पर फोन नल था उसे डाटा चाहिए
तो देखो ये अपना पी वाला डाटा ए गया है
ठीक है
कहां पर अपना डाटा नहीं फिर कर रखा है इधर
छोटा सा टेबल है जब बड़े-बड़े टेबल्स होते
हैं वहां अपन को ये कम ए सकता है
बस ये चेक करता है कहां पे वैल्यू नल है
मैं तो कोल्लम का डाटा
है और देखो अगर मां लो की ना आप लोगों को
यह
जितना भी लिखा हुआ है क्लीन करना है
जैसे
क्लीन करने के लिए चीज हनी चाहिए तो इसके
अंदर भी है जैसे
हां देखो क्लियर स्क्रीन लिखने ही सर का
सरल साफ हो के देखो अगर मैं थोड़ा सा ऐसे
इसको गंदा कर देता हूं
उसको
साफ करने का है
इसको पूरा स्क्रीन क्लियर हो जाएगा
मतलब बैंड हो जाएगा
मैंने टाइम बच्चा है तो मैंने सोचा की मैं
कर ही देता हूं तो इस नदी में ने कराई
दिया है
की नहीं देखो मैंने छोटा ही रखा क्योंकि
यार क्योंकि इसके आगे वाला तो कॉन्सेप्ट
थोड़ा सा हैवी कॉन्सेप्ट है ठीक है ना तो
अपन ऐसा नहीं किया अपन को बस दिन खत्म
करने हैं की अपने से जल्दी से मुझे खत्म
करना है ऐसा कुछ बिल्कुल भी नहीं है अपन
चीज को आराम से लेक चलेंगे क्योंकि अपन को
थोड़ा चीजों को अंदर तक समझना का है सब
कुछ डीपी समझना का है मैं करते करते करते
करते खत्म कर सकता हूं लेकिन मैं वो खत्म
नहीं करना छह रहा हूं
मतलब अपना यार समझना मटर करता है देखो
समझ में आनी मटर करती है
कोई भी आपको कोर्स कर के कंप्लीट कर देगा
मतलब कॉलेज के अंदर ही देख लो यार अपना
मतलब लाइव पीछे वहां पे सामने खड़ा हो के
कोर्स निपटाना होता है उसको तो निपटा आगे
निकाल जाता है
लेकिन यहां पर अगर सिम बिल्कुल भी नहीं है
यहां पर आपको समझ में आना चाहिए और आपको
कैसा चल रहा है कैसे कम करती है चीज वो
चीज आपको समझ में आने से आपके सारे डाउट
सॉल्व होने चाहिए वहां पर हम लोग ज्यादा
फॉक्स करते हैं
ठीक है ना तो आज का आपका जो टास्क है
क्या आपको समझ में आया की नहीं
की
यह सेट ऑपरेटर कैसे कम किया
यह बताओ
पी कर सकते हो ठीक है तो जैसे अपन ये वाला
समझ में नहीं आया ये क्या है क्या नहीं है
तो आपको वहां की मैं आपको गाइड कर दिया
जाएगा
आपको सॉल्यूशन मिल जाएगा नेता अगर मुझे
टाइप करोगे जल्दी मिल जाए आपको सॉल्यूशन
कैसे करेंगे वो आपको मुझे करके बताना है
यहां पर सामने और स्क्रीनशॉट
की अपना
क्रोम में जाना है जो भी आपके ब्राउज़र पर
जाना
क्या देखो जिनका अकाउंट
से वेट नहीं किया क्योंकि मैंने रिसेंटली
कुछ ज्यादा कुछ किया नहीं है इसके लिए
है कमेंट में जाना है और कमेंट में जान के
बाद मैं आपको जो टास्क में बोलेंगे की यू
नो डॉक्टर वगैरा को 2 से अधिक टेबल के साथ
में ट्राई करो तो आपको मुझे ट्राई करके
भेज देना
वहां पर डिस्कशन में आप दाल सकते हो यार
देखो मैंने देखा है ना अपने टेलीग्राम
चैनल पे तो है लेकिन डिस्कशन वो लोग जॉइन
नहीं कर सकते
हैं आप लोग कम्युनिटी के साथ रहो
हेल्प करने के लिए रहेंगे
तो वहां पर भी हेल्प ले सकते हो तो आपको
सारे लिंक जो है इस वीडियो के किसी भी
वीडियो के डिस्क्रिप्शन में आपको सारे
लिंक मिल जाएंगे
जितने भी हैं तो वहां पर जाकर आप जाकर
जॉइन कर सकते हो
थैंक यू टाटा बाय बाय सी यू गुड नाइट
शब्बा खैर और डेफिनेट कीजिए अब मिलते हैं
कल कल का सीजन थोड़ा सा हैवी र सकता है तो
प्लीज अंकल आना जरूर हो यार पीछे का
रिवर्स करके आना बट कल अपन जोइंस करने
वाले हैं ठीक है
ना थोड़ा हो सके तो पढ़ के भी ए जाना
जॉइंट्स वगैरा के बड़े में क्या राहत है
कहानी राहत है ठीक है